ladies and gentlemen one of the biggest
political stories of the year of the
decade of the entire time that i've been
covering politics took place last night
august 8th the anniversary of the
resignation of president richard nixon
from his office
the fbi executed a search warrant at
donald trump's home mar-a-lago including
a search of his personal quarters as
well as of a safe it is an incredible
situation this all happening in
connection with donald trump taking
those massive dumps of classified
documents to his own house
nbc reporting fbi search at trump's
mar-a-lago home tied to classified
material in a lengthy statement monday
night trump said they even broke into my
safe former president trump said monday
the fbi raided his home at mar-a-lago
and cracked his safe a source familiar
with the matter said to nbc news it was
all tied to the classified information
that donald trump took with him from the
white house in january of 2021.
this is an extraordinary situation the
claims being made by those on the right
are beyond parody and we will get to
that but first and foremost donald
trump's own reaction to this putting out
an unhinged statement
saying the following
these are dark times
for our nation as my beautiful home
mar-a-lago in palm beach florida is
currently under siege raided and
occupied by a large group of fbi agents
nothing like this has ever happened to a
president of the united states before
after working and cooperating with the
relevant government agencies this
unannounced raid on my home was not
necessary or appropriate the fact that
trump is saying he was cooperating to me
suggests he wasn't because he basically
lies about everything it is a
prosecutorial misconduct the
weaponization of the justice system and
an attack by radical left democrats who
desperately don't want me to run for
president in 2024 especially based on
recent polls now remember the current
director of the fbi is christopher wray
appointed by donald trump so to claim
that this is the work of far-left
democrats it is being asserted without
evidence and until evidence is presented
i believe we can dismiss it as there is
no evidence
trump going on to say such an assault
could only take place in broken third
world countries sadly america has now
become one of those capital c countries
corrupt at a level not seen before
wow they even broke into my safe
what is the difference between this and
watergate where operatives broke into
the dnc here in reverse democrats broke
into the home of the 45th president of
the united states big massive dumps well
that's all going to remain to be seen i
do hope given trump's propensity to
flush evidence down the toilet i hope
the fbi has plumbers on staff and that
they have appropriate elements of
plumbing with suction in order to figure
out what on earth did trump flush down
that toilet what records did he destroy
so trump blaming this on the radical
left the truth is trump selected the fbi
director who would have had to sign off
on this and just as a reminder here is
donald trump praising the great
christopher wray from the fbi president
trump is just tweeting about the fbi
director here's what he says i will be
nominating christopher a ray a man of
impeccable credentials to be the next
director of the fbi details to follow
right that's the guy now that trump is
saying
is the radical left
going after him now understand such a
decision to raid the house of a former
president
it must have been approved by the
attorney general merrick garland
the top echelon of the fbi must have
known about it that is one very bad news
for donald trump and second
you don't do this on a whim
the fbi also would have required
probable cause
to have a belief that there were
specific places again trump's personal
quarters trump safe they would have to
have probable cause to be able to say
here's where we want to search
it wouldn't be a shock
if a very high-level trump associate
flipped and was cooperating with the fbi
we don't know that but for them to have
such probable cause about the specific
places in trump's home to be searched
could it have been mark meadows we don't
know it's all speculative but the most
important part of this is that when
trump says they broke into my safe and
later you'll hear eric trump say there
was nothing in it which is interesting
they would need some reason to include
the safe as a search location they would
have some reason to think that the safe
might have a nexus to potentially
criminal activity now if the raid was
only about some low-level staffer and
not about trump or someone near trump
it's unlikely they would go into his
personal safe again we're reading tea
leaves and speculating based on what we
do know
um they couldn't have done this
if they didn't have a good case to do it
and that the belief at least the
plausible belief that mar-a-lago
contained evidence of criminal activity
now attorney mark elias pointed out
the media is missing the really big
reason why the raid is a potential
blockbuster in american politics and
that relates to
18 u.s code subsection 2071 the
concealment removal and mutilation
generally and it says
that if indeed one is found guilty of
mishandling documents in this way
concealing removing mutilating
obliterating
the penalty is forfeiture of public
office and disqualification from holding
any office under the united states
that's potentially what is at play here
assuming that this involves the
mishandling or unauthorized removal of
classified information and if they find
those elements at mar-a-lago
the substance of the documents is less
important it's the fact that they were
classified and that they were improperly
removed their presence alone would be
indicative of this crime now again we're
going to get to clips in a moment of all
the people saying everything done was
improper
uh merrick garland would not have
authorized this and a federal judge
would not have okayed it if there was
not significant evidence to warrant it
and recall with hillary clinton's case
the doj didn't prosecute because she may
have been negligent with information
maybe she was even reckless but it was
not an intentional mishandling that rose
to criminality and if this is what
happened at mar-a-lago we have to
believe that at least potentially that
is what the fbi believes donald trump
did
let's get now to mega world exploding
over the fbi raiding donald trump's
house they are throwing everything at
the wall to see what sticks they're all
going crazy they're doing emergency
podcasts they're saying this is going to
be the undoing of the republic it is a
dystopian hellscape it is over for the
united states because of the fbi raiding
donald trump let's look at some examples
these are great
here's mark levin
calling this one of the worst attacks on
the republic in modern history now you
keep asking your guests what's the
justification there is no justification
what's he going to say tomorrow the
attorney general here's my guess
we've been negotiating with trump and
his lawyers since february when we found
out they had this information we were
getting nowhere and then we know or we
heard that some documents were being
destroyed maggie hagerman of the new
york slimes
was on cnn they've been running pictures
of hers that she's going to have in the
book
of documents being flushed on a toilet
that doesn't mean a damn thing it could
be anything
phonics name on it that's all it was
okay but what i'm saying is you've asked
what would the pretext be
correct and so it is a pretext is
exactly right
there is no justification for sending 30
friggin fbi agents to the former
president's compound in mar-a-lago in
early morning and conducting themselves
this way or in any other cases in which
they've done exactly the same thing the
fbi is corrupt this guy garland goes
after parents he goes after republican
state legislatures he goes after states
he disagrees with their abortion
positions he doesn't do a damn thing to
protect the border which is compelled by
the constitution nothing
so let's be clear
newt is right they're all right
this is the worst attack on this
republic in modern history so levin is
flipping out but the truth is this would
not have happened were there not
significant eyes dotted in t's cross
next we go to newsmax guest bernie
carrick
not a guy unfamiliar with legal problems
and he said he's worried the next step
is they're going to assassinate donald
trump and i just put out a tweet about
this
if you remember back in 2016 when i when
right before he got elected i was in
washington dc i was at a couple
different social events and i hear
people talking
they said the democrats want this guy so
bad
that they wouldn't put assassination
behind it
and and i'm going to tell you something
they've tried impeachment
they've tried another impeachment
they've tried one investigation after
another this is about one thing
this is about stopping him from running
in 2024
and i'm going to tell you something i'm
not into conspiracies i'm not into
anti-government rhetoric
this is the first time in my lifetime
that i would say i am deathly afraid for
donald trump i would not put
assassination
behind these people right
a raid based on probable cause a warrant
signed by a judge and everything done
properly could very clearly be a pretext
to assassinating donald trump here's
radical republican congresswoman lauren
beaubert saying this is the gestapo guys
i'm pissed we are a nation of law and
order and this raid by the fbi on
president trump's home is totally
unamerican this is gestapo crap and it
will not stand well you know i don't
remember the gestapo regularly having
sworn affidavits court orders signed by
a judge and all of it when they
conducted raids many such examples i
think you understand alex jones and
roger stone
uh convening an emergency podcast over
the raid likening it to nazi germany
who's as a former political prisoner
himself and what he believes this means
roger stone thanks for joining us on
this emergency broadcast it's an
emergency alex it's a it's a very very
sad day for america
this is the kind of thing you expect to
see in soviet russia nazi germany
communist cuba
they don't know how to handle this sean
hannity we covered this last night on
the live stream he spoke for about 11
minutes without taking a breath and here
is some of his dystopian outlook on what
took place first a dark day for our
republic the department of justice the
rule of law what looks to be potentially
a shocking overreach we'll find out in
due time that will have serious
ramifications
potentially for many many years to come
a lot of potentialities in there
potentially doing very very heavy
lifting for sean hannity marjorie taylor
green now says on twitter quote defund
the fbi
not exactly support the police type uh
behavior by marjorie taylor greene and
then lastly right-wing bomb thrower dan
bongino saying that the left thinks this
is all hilarious
i just want to say in closing
listen america they're laughing at you
the left thinks this is hilarious if you
doubt me just go to any of their goofy
platforms twitter elsewhere right now
they think this is hilarious now i have
to tell you bongino is correct to a
certain degree
i do think this is absolutely hilarious
but it also seems to be completely
appropriate based on the facts that we
have known for a very long time
no one that commits crimes against the
american people should feel safe and
there's a lot of people that commit
crimes and do feel safe because we have
a two-tiered justice system we don't
know where this will go
but we are going to follow it and you've
got to see eric trump's reaction to all
of this
so in the midst of the fbi raid of
donald trump's mar-a-lago home and the
right-wing going apoplectic to try to
figure out how can we attack what
happened here today
eric trump
not known as trump's smartest child but
that's okay
eric trump goes on fox news
and is so visibly triggered that he
doesn't even know what he's saying first
starting with the epitome of the
victimhood that the trumps are the
biggest victims in the united states you
know they went after him they went after
all of us there's no family in american
history that has taken more arrows in
the back
than the trump family every single time
right if you think of families who have
been destroyed by
simply having family members imprisoned
due to having drugs if you think of
families who have lost children in mass
shootings if you think of families who
can't even afford to feed their children
no no no no no it is the trump family
that has been the most victimized of any
family then eric trump pulling
everything out of the hat bringing up
benghazi and going back to hillary
there's a whole lot of other things how
about the big aussie scandals how about
the clinton foundation i mean how many
you know shady oligarchs from russia
were contributing to that look about how
about uranium one you want to talk about
you know scandals that were never
investigated never vetted yeah you know
i remember was it eight was it 12
investigations into benghazi benghazi
was a tragedy it was horrible what
happened but hillary's involvement was
investigated up and down she testified
under oath for eight hours something
donald trump has not done give me a
break eric then goes on and says there
wasn't even anything in the safe that
they ransacked they get another subpoena
and they do it for one reason because
they don't want donald trump to run and
win again in 2024 and sean that's what
this is about today to have 30 fbi
agents actually more than that descend
on mar-a-lago give absolutely
you know no notice go through the gates
start ransacking an office ransacking a
closet you know they broke into a safe
he didn't even have anything in the safe
now if there was nothing in the safe
that's almost more suspicious i'd be
wondering where was the stuff moved to
um
then lastly eric trump
saying where are where did these fbi
agents go anyway you know shady deals
with everybody around the world and by
the way it's all on his laptop for the
whole world to see
in his own writing and his own words
corroborated by everybody
where were these fbi agents where where
is everybody why
so eric trump highly triggered and
making no sense at all
let's now allow some time
to let this settle and develop
we will learn more about it and we will
see where it ultimately goes what i want
to ask you is do you believe this is
finally the levy breaking do you believe
an indictment is coming let me know find
me on twitter at dpakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
could the coming 2022 midterm election
be the worst midterm ever for
republicans
in this particular situation the
situation being one that should be very
good for the republican party if you
look historically i know many of you are
sick of hearing this from me but i want
to remind everybody normally when one
party takes the white house from the
other party
in the first midterm election after that
that very party then loses a bunch of
seats or potentially control of the
house or senate meaning because
democrats took the white house from
republicans in 2020 2022 should be very
very good for republicans and it was
looking that way for a very long time
and all of a sudden in the last month
and in particular in the last two weeks
things are looking dramatically
different
we mentioned yesterday
the senate has approved this inflation
reduction act bill to fight climate
change and cut drug costs this is a
major accomplishment assuming that the
house passes it on friday and then it is
signed by joe biden both of which are
expected to happen
this is a massive biden accomplishment
and then when you look bigger picture at
the biden accomplishments you see
that he did the covet stimulus he did
the infrastructure and jobs act he
confirmed the first black female supreme
court justice
he did some gun safety legislation
although i think it's pretty weak sauce
but at least it was something
he did the chips act for semiconductor
manufacturing the nato expansion to
include finland and sweden is in process
he expanded veterans health care
he authorized the strike that killed
terrorist ayman al-zawahiri which
believe me i understand there are legal
questions about
whether the united states can or should
be doing that but it is an
accomplishment that biden can claim
fantastic jobs report last week
3.5 unemployment
55 straight days of gas price reduction
which again remember i don't even think
it has anything to do with biden i don't
think the upswing had anything to do
with biden i don't think the downswing
has anything to do with joe biden either
but the point is what is reported and
what can you take credit for and
tomorrow
we have an inflation number coming out
which i expect to be significantly lower
than the peak numbers we saw over the
last few months i may be wrong but
that's what i expect and if that's the
case it will be another indicator that
the economy is looking better and better
overall
could this be
a disastrous midterm for republicans
well the polling data is increasingly
pointing that way
after looking
for months and months like republicans
were going to take the senate
definitively from democrats in the fall
the 538 uh forecast for the senate now
has democrats at 59 percent likely to
retain control of the senate now
that's not
overwhelming but it is looking
increasingly good for democrats in terms
of the senate now in the house it's not
looking very good it still looks like
about an 80 percent chance that
republicans win remember 80 is not a
hundred percent but that's the way that
it is looking right now
this is a massive massive reversal from
the way things looked and quite frankly
the way things should look speaking
historically for republicans
what do you think we're going to see in
november and then the last piece of this
is we spoke about this a little bit with
political scientists rachel bittikoffer
last week she has a slightly different
view on it than i do and i know many of
you have different views about this
because of the overturning of roe v wade
this actually does seem like it is a
midterm election
where running on abortion rights on
women having autonomy over their medical
decisions
could be very good for democrats
typically it is not an issue that is so
good for democrats uh extraordinary
circumstances and as i've said before
there are some elections which just
don't feel like they're that important
the 2022 midterm
and the 2024 presidential election which
are honestly one in the same i mean the
24 election is almost getting going
right now and we're going to look at
some of those numbers later as well
because what is happening with trump and
desantis is extraordinary
um
could this be a disaster for republicans
let me know what you think
we've been covering
what's going on in the georgia senate
race this is the race in which former
football player herschel walker
is the republican nominee he became the
republican nominee without even
participating in a debate and now the
question is will herschel walker debate
raphael warnock rafael warnock is the
incumbent senator a democrat in georgia
the backstory on herschel walker that
has been notable is that he is almost
unable to speak and almost unable to
express himself
and to give us his opinion on any issue
he's asked questions and he puts
together word salads of no meaning
whatsoever
and there are questions as to whether he
is even going to debate raphael warnock
recently
herschel walker has started to claim
that he has accepted a debate
and the language to the extent that we
can decipher it is bizarre it's about a
debate in raphael warnock's backyard
it's not going to be for the press but
it's going to be for the fans
and it's extraordinarily weird and over
the last week we have confirmed that
herschel walker still can't speak and
probably won't debate here is one
appearance over the weekend by herschel
walker on fox business
and he i i gather he's talking about
whether he will debate
but what he says is completely
unintelligible see if you can understand
it november are you going to debate him
well i've
called him on two debates i called him
on two debates what does that mean
it means nothing on two debates he
turned me down on both of them because i
said what i want to do is see a fair and
accurate debate i have seen no evidence
that rafael warnock has turned down two
debates whereas for the people not about
some press not about some party but the
people get a chance to see the
differences between my opponent and
myself when my opponent believed in
raising taxes during a recession my
opponent believed being soft on crime he
voted with joe biden to elect officials
that is soft on crime my opponent
believed that he voted to put men and
remember the question was are you going
to debate in sports where i do not think
men should be in women's sports so
there's a big difference in contrast i
think he's afraid to stand in front of
his georgia voters and stand up for the
record that he's voted on that that is
meaningless now if there is such a
debate i will cover it that would be an
extraordinary debate to cover
but
i am not getting the sense that herschel
walker actually plans to debate
how could he debate if he can't even
answer the question are you going to
debate it doesn't make any sense and you
know he speaks with this very scrambled
syntax and it's almost like trying to
decipher a verbal morse code to listen
to herschel walker but again i don't
know why it was ever claimed that he
agreed to a debate because the more i
listen to him
it sounds like he's maybe saying there's
going to be a town hall i i don't really
know here's another clip of uh herschel
walker
i hesitate to use the word explaining
but he's talking i guess about this
debate senator warner
next star media group offered to host a
debate for us in savannah
now by the way these are the new videos
that walker's doing very clearly reading
off of some kind of notes
even reading off of the notes i still
don't know what the hell he's talking
about october the 14th in front of the
people don't be scared
i know you rejected previous offers i
made no evidence of that
but please consider this one
this debate is more than fair to you
and it's for the people
it's in your own backyard savannah
right you have hometown advantage
it's being hosted by a respected
third-party media group with multiple
outlets in georgia
it would be aired statewide on broadcast
television by the way next star is like
this right-wing media company
i'm sure they would host the debate but
again nobody knows what walker is
talking about in prime time
so everybody will get a chance to watch
it
it's a prime time showdown in savannah
you know i mean
come on raphael let's do this
for georgia
october the 14th
i'll be there
were you
yeah
um it sort of sounds like what walker
wants to do is some kind of town hall
it's not even clear what he's talking
about to be perfectly frank but i have
to tell you
when trumpists are your supporters
there's no downside to walker just
saying
i want a debate and raphael warnock
won't do it
and of course it'll be a made-up lie
warnock
might be perfectly willing to debate in
fact i believe he is but what walker
should do if i were listen if i were his
advisors i would not want him to debate
i mean he can't speak so how can you
debate
i would advise him start claiming that
warnock won't debate you make it up
it'll be a lie i think that actually is
his best strategy and a lot of his
followers will believe it let me know
your thoughts and we'll have these clips
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow it is great to welcome
to the program today andrew sullivan
who's a blogger at the weekly dish his
book now out in paperback is out on a
limb collected writing from 1989 to 2021
you know andrew it's so great to have
you on because
as a progressive my very left-wing
audience will say
who on the right is interesting to
listen to because i'm not getting what i
need intellectually from matt gates for
example
uh and i will often say you know i
actually think andrew sullivan writes a
lot of really interesting things but the
the strange thing is
i see very little in common at this
point between you and sort of where the
american republican party is i mean do
do you feel like you still see your
politics in that party
i've never seen my politics in that
political party
um never identified as a republican
have
been pretty
hostile to successive republican
presidents i mean
bush and trump for example a big
supporter of obama no my
my view is really from a more english
conservative position
of limited government
of free society
um skepticism about grand
changes to society in general
and a belief in the west and its core
values and
and that meant that i did not have a
huge problem for example
in supporting barack obama whom i
regarded as a bit of a moderate a bit of
an old school actually
i always thought of him as a 1970s kind
of republican um
and so i i don't fit in is the truth but
i am definitely not a lefty and i'm
definitely not
uh a liberal in the progressive sense i
uh i'm a skeptic of those those
traditions when you look at
to pick something specific
the increased willingness from the
modern american right wing to use
government power to achieve
whatever it is they're looking to
achieve
rather than stepping back into what
might be called small government
conservatism doing the absolute least
does that concern you above and beyond
just you know whether you identify with
the movement or not because it's
antithetical to the way you believe
governments should operate or is it is
it not as brought a concern as some more
traditional conservatives point out
i think that
at some level you know the right in
terms of the culture war particularly
does have a right to self-defense i mean
i and i don't think that's completely
outrageous i don't think it's outrageous
for example that
we should have states decide what their
abortion regime is going to be through
democratic processes i i i don't think
it's
crazy for a state
for example to look at its own
educational curriculum and positions and
if it's that has been altered
dramatically in ways that the
the politics of the state doesn't quite
accept then i don't think it's out of
bounds
for a governor or school boards to do
within the classic democratic tradition
a change of policy or a reversal of
policy uh
but i do think there's a sense of using
the state as a wielding sort of a weapon
to punish people
uh so for example let me give you a
desantis
uh he's perfectly within his rights to
say
no in in florida we are going to through
the legislature change
uh curriculum and and pass this this law
it's another thing
for him then to use the power of the
governor to punish a company disney for
disagreeing with him see there's a
distinction there and i think sometimes
uh it can get muddled up i don't think
the right has to constantly disarm but i
do think the right has lost a sense of
the limits of government
the need to let society evolve on its
own and to be
tolerant of other points of view and
allow them
their place in the sun and that that
goes for both sides by the way and i
think a great deal of the pushback
from the right on some of these culture
issues is a response to regressive acts
by the progressive left when it comes to
democratically deciding abortion law at
the state level like you mentioned
kansas had an actual vote of the people
of the population other states like
indiana it's legislators who got
together and said we're banning it after
i think six weeks is the latest proposal
with very very few exceptions one could
argue that that's democratic in the
sense that
it's legislators elected by the people
who are deciding that but it runs
counter to public opinion as best we can
tell at this point in time so are both
of those examples of democratically
deciding or is only when the people vote
an example of that
well i think the kansas thing was a very
particular
question because they'd already had some
sort of uh
decision barring uh
that made some kind of vote yes as a
referendum inevitable no no i don't
think it really matters how that
democracy is pursued it may be that in
the short term for example there are
lots of people in republicans elected as
state legislatures who are more to the
right
on abortion than most of their voters
are absolutely well vote them out or
or or or let your views be known to them
to make sure they're not following some
pre-existing ideological commitment
which you know for many years it was so
easy for republicans to say i'm for
batting all abortion period and they
would never called on it because no one
was ever going to be enforcing it now
that it's having to be enforced i think
you're going to get actual real
compromises and decisions that are made
state by state and i think liberals or
pro-life brew choices in general
are way too pessimistic about their
chances in that process and i think
we'll probably end up in the u.s
pretty not that far away
from many countries in western europe
and although we will have some outliers
on the conservative front but you know
america is more conservative than parts
of europe and i i i don't have a problem
with states coming to different
positions on questions like that the
other because we're talking about a lot
of cultural and social issues it was
notable to me
i've sort of seen this building and look
in watching trump rallies over the last
year to 18 months but it was very
notable at cpac
that the biggest applause lines were the
more overtly homophobic and transphobic
lines jokes about pronouns uh you know i
i don't have the full list in front of
me but when you saw the crowd really get
excited they were dead when trump was
talking about himself as the biggest
victim in the history of the western of
western civilization that did not excite
the crowd too much but the stuff about
trans swimmers and ted cruz's pronouns
and there it really excited the crowd do
you agree that there's been a sort of
resurgence of that sentiment in the
modern american right and are you
concerned about it
i think i am within some
aspects of the conservative right i mean
we're talking about
the texas cpac so we are talking about
the pretty hardcore
fanatics and they are so polarized that
anything
pro gay for example gets attacked but
when you actually look at the polling
data of regular republicans you now see
a majority of republicans favoring
marriage equality what i do think you're
seeing uh is a an understandable
response
to a very aggressive push
by essentially uh
gender
uh
queer and gender critical theorists to
redefine what sex is to redefine what
gender is and to teach those
redefinitions to three to four-year-olds
without their parents even being
informed and i think that has led to a
backlash i honestly think it's
understandable it's led to a backlash
and there are plenty of us who are very
supportive of gay and trans rights who
are not
nonetheless wedded to this rather
post-modern understanding the biological
sex is basically non-existent that you
pick and choose whichever gender you
have and that there are more than 55
different genders to pick from and all
of them trump sex in every particular
instance i don't buy any of that and i
think insofar as there's been resistance
to it
it's been a function of the left
overreaching rather than the right uh
demonstrating its its intolerance that's
not to say i defend some of this stuff
well i mean
some of the ugly some of the things you
just said i'm also against i've just not
seen them being taught to four-year-olds
anywhere i mean where and i'm i'm not
saying this rhetorically like where are
they teaching four-year-olds that there
is no biological basis at all for gender
and that there's 55 choices to be made i
just haven't seen that
well um i recommend you check a couple
pieces i've done recently uh at the
weekly dish on this
um state curricular are now mandating
places that were as in florida as in new
jersey and there are other places
with that gender identity and homosexual
and sexual orientation be taught from
kindergarten onwards now how that is
translated
is a different question but i can also
show you plenty of children's books
plenty of lesson plans in which this is
uh argued for as early as three or four
and what they say of of course they're
not using words like biological sex or
they're saying and this is the phrase
that comes across
uh quite starkly to me
you this is this is to a child who at
kindergarten you can be a boy or a girl
or both or neither or something else
entirely and it's up to you to choose
well i don't i honestly i i think
telling three-year-olds that before they
even wrap their heads around boy and
girl
uh seems to me
outrageously over the top and certainly
not something a lot of gay people even
think should be taught and certainly
affects gay kids who themselves
have a slightly different perspective
which is that yes we're boys
but we just happen to be attracted to
other boys now they may not be they will
not be aware of that in any real sense
at three four five i don't see there's a
problem with restricting it to kids who
are eight years old or above and i don't
think that's some sort of fascist move i
think that i think the ideals got out of
control and they're being uh slightly
reigned back in and i i don't think
that's the end of the world
yeah i mean
it's hard for me to respond
substantively because i just haven't
seen what you're describing so i'll do
some research on that i think as books
yeah they're really
there they're ways in which you
translate it
uh to children and i think it can be
rather disorienting
for children to be taught this that
young
as a political question what would you
like to see the american right whether
it's through the republican party or
outside of it wherever you you follow it
what should be the substance of the
platforms on which those candidates run
because especially in the trump era they
don't even really pretend to be about
economic policy they'll vaguely talk
about taxes and regulation but there's
very little substance there uh there i
like what substance is it this stuff the
stuff about what four-year-olds are
taught because that seems sort of flimsy
as well as a platform
it is flimsy as a platform um but i do
think there is a potent policy mix
that's on the table
and that is for the republican party to
go left on economics
to do things like supporting like take
the pro-life position if they actually
got their act together and decided to
really fund health care for
pregnant women uh that they actually did
put some beef behind support for
bringing children into the world
along with more restrictions on abortion
then i think they'd have much a fairer
hearing at least
and i think moving left on economics in
terms of trade
i think uh moving right on
immigration
and that combination with a certain
amount of cultural not right wingery but
conservatism in the sense that we don't
really want to redefine gender we don't
want to suddenly decide that everyone
has to overcome
whiteness in order to become a fully
functioning member of society those
kinds of things i think that's a very
potent
uh platform it's potent in europe and it
would be potent here if it hadn't been
consumed by all this awful authoritarian
instincts by the cult worship of trump
by the
anti-institutional
anti-conservative radicalism
of many of these groups um and
i i think there is a center there a
center right that will be
made anew in the new world around
nationalism around trade around
immigration but that could be sane
and would work very well and
unfortunately i think the republican
party seems
currently incapable of coming up with
that is there anybody right now that
embodies that i mean who when you i know
you don't like trump my guess is you're
not big on desantis is are there people
currently in politics in the u.s that
match this ideology that you're talking
about
well look desantis has a certain edge to
him and he's he's posing as trump
essentially at this point yes but when
you look at his early time in florida
when you look at for example he's been
quite sensible and pragmatic on climate
change in terms of resilience in florida
he's been doing quite a lot of sane
stuff on the environment
i think if you could get past the the
personality cult of someone like trump
and i think if you could start
delivering so for example if trump had
actually delivered on his wall even
though he didn't i do think you could
have a more successful presidency than
you did with trump but trump
is just suey generous he is a crazy
person
he has attacked this country's
institutions and its democracy he should
not be anywhere near political office so
from my point of view unless that is
resolved
we can't support i can't support
anything republican but if a republican
were to emerge she would actually
acknowledge and recognize our
constitutional order
he can reform the institutions but not
destroy them
and create a policy agenda that is more
left economically a more right socially
then that's a perfectly decent outcome
for the future of the right in america
the question is who can do it i think to
be honest with you i have an open mind
about whether desantis is that person or
whether he is not that person uh and
we'll see
people like mitt romney and liz cheney
how what's your perspective on them
i i
i have what we call newfound respect for
liz cheney i do think that what she's
done has required courage and integrity
and i think she's right i really do
i think mitt romney's move on supporting
family life and the economic stresses of
young families with kids who are
struggling to get by
is also
very positive um i hope
i it seems to me that until we get rid
of trump someone like liz chaney is not
going to be a player but
she's got a long life and we don't know
what happens but i'm i'm very happy i
said about you but when i look back at
my worry about romney in 2012 i'm like
jesus give me romney any day of the week
now he would be far preferable to these
these nut balls and he's
he's a good guy you know at some point
just someone who respects the rule of
law
and the constitution and says so
publicly is such a relief on the
republican side no i know what you mean
i recently rewatched this netflix
documentary about romney's i believe it
was the 2012 run
and without
you know rehabilitating his policies
specifically which i preferred obama at
the time but it's hard to feel like it
would have been a crisis if mitt romney
had won in 2012 in the way that we've
seen in the last four years because he
seems so comparatively benign and
inoffensive
there are two things here you can
disagree with someone's policies yeah
that's what democracy is right right you
vote for the other guy but when you lose
trust in that person's respect for the
system for the institutions and for the
rule of law it's something else entirely
we since trump became the nominee we
have been a different world
we have been in a democratic emergency
because this is someone at the center of
our system who despises our system and
who will seek to undermine it doesn't
even understand it so
putting that aside it would be lovely to
get back
to a really good debate about policy
right how do we best protect the
environment you know i mean and the
current bill for example
is a bit of a hodgepodge isn't it but
it's a decent hodgepodge it's a
compromise that moves things forward
and i the same with abortion in the
states even though you may hate the idea
it's being done
it's still a process a political process
find a compromise move things forward in
a way and that's all liberal democracy
should be about we're not about solving
every human problem we're about making
things a bit better if we can and i want
to kind of dial back
these existential claims about what
politics can do
and get back to
the difficult unsatisfying but
absolutely
phenomenally important compromising
legislating and i think that the current
congress
after a rough start has begun to hit its
stride on that i agree i will be i'll be
very interested to see how the public
responds yeah because i think the public
wants this i really do
even it won't solve everything it shows
that we can do something
and i hope i hope that's rewarded yeah
and some of the polling data over the
last two months suggests that uh
things are looking different for a
midterm than than they would
historically be expected to look we'll
have to wait two and a half months now
and see
um the book now out in paperback is out
on a limb collected writing from 89 to
2021 we've been speaking with blogger
andrew sullivan whose work you can read
at the weekly dish so great having you
on
thanks so much for for having this
conversation i'm i'm really really
grateful to be part of it
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
okay a couple of other quick stories
that we've been covering the alex jones
text messages have made their way to the
trump riot committee based on reporting
from a number of different sources so
let's back up and to remind you what's
going on
we knew before the alex jones defamation
trial that jones was involved and in
contact with uh people that were
organizing and at the trump riots on
january 6 2021.
we
knew that it would be great if alex
jones was somehow more involved than
under scrutiny from the january 6
committee but it wasn't clear if and how
that was going to happen then the alex
jones defamation trial took place and as
you might remember alex jones own
bone-headed lawyer
accidentally sent
a full digital copy
of jones entire mobile phone including
text messages and other things to the
attorney representing the plaintiffs in
the defamation trial and there was
cartoonish stuff in there like for
example there was a record of alex jones
sending according to the plaintiff's
attorney alex jones sent a naked picture
of his own wife
to roger stone like bizarre cartoonish
stuff
but also because of the timeline of
those text messages in that digital copy
it was reasonable to believe or to
expect or to wonder that materials
related to january 6th also would have
been on that digital copy and then we
learned the january 6 committee wants
alex jones text messages and now the
reporting from cnn is alex jones texts
have been turned over to the january 6
committee the article reads
approximately two years worth of text
messages sent and received by conspiracy
theorist alex jones have been turned
over to the house select committee
investigating the january 6th
insurrection a person familiar with the
matter said to cnn
the messages were handed over to the
committee by mark bankston the attorney
who represented the sandy hook parents
who successfully sued jones in texas and
won nearly 50 million dollars in the
civil trial bankston would only tell cnn
that he is cooperating with the
committee the committee declined to
comment during the trial as you might
recall bankston revealed one of jones
lawyers messed up and inadvertently sent
him the two years of text messages that
bankston uh and bankston also said
during the trial the committee expressed
interest in the material you know it's a
really good thing
that so many of the people
behind january 6th
involved in january 6 and in this case
representing individuals involved with
january 6 speaking of course of alex
jones attorney
are kind of doofuses it's very useful
and it aids the investigation to proceed
that a lot of these people don't seem to
be playing with a full deck or you know
uh the wheel is spinning but the
hamster's dead whatever metaphor or
phrase you want to apply to it now none
of this means that there are going to be
consequences i think as we now have
learned of the fbi rate of donald
trump's mar-a-lago home
it's entertaining
it feels like at least he's suffering a
little because they raided his home
but i am not assuming that trump is
going to be indicted or that if he is
that there will be consequences we will
have to wait and see and similarly
the fact that the committee now has the
text messages of alex jones
even though it was not jones intention
for the committee to have them it
doesn't necessarily mean that there's
going to be consequences now one of the
things that
uh
is important to remember is anytime
you're dealing with leaks or transfers
of information the right wingers love to
pull this double standard when it came
to the hunter biden laptop they didn't
care
how the blind computer tech got it
they didn't care about anything in terms
of due process or discovery or finding
it it didn't matter it was what's on the
laptop
now they're saying what hold on a second
what about due process this was an
accident what about attorney-client
privilege what about invasion of privacy
what about free speech they'll throw
whatever they can at the wall to say the
content of the text messages does not
matter all that matters is how did the
january 6 committee obtain the text
messages predictable people we will see
what happens and what the next step is
in terms of the committee and alex jones
remember the committee expected to hold
more hearings i believe they said in
september so we will see
one little final follow-up from the
weekend cpac
this is sarah palin
sarah palin is fascinating we have
covered sarah palin for a really long
time because back in 2008 she was the
late senator john mccain's vice
presidential running mate and at the
time she became known to us
for her incomparable word salads and her
abject failure at using language to
communicate she just couldn't do it she
you saw her mouth moving
you heard things coming out some of them
were words but it didn't fit together in
any way that made sense it's sort of
like if you made a dish for dinner and
like you see a plate
and you're aware that there's pasta
uh in the toilet and you saw tomato
sauce on top of the fridge like
individually these are elements of food
but it's not coming together in any way
that makes sense now similarly when
sarah palin appeared at cpac over the
weekend
she was um
apparently trying to quote
uh
abraham lincoln
and she is so visibly confused and so
incoherently trying to use language that
i don't know what the hell she's talking
about it also looks like she has a
massive gaudy star of david hanging from
her neck i mean every aspect of this is
whacked and whatever is going on with
her seems to be getting worse and worse
maybe she was referring to a lincoln log
i don't know but this doesn't sound like
anything i've ever heard lincoln say
person what they're doing is usurping
the the power from the other two
branches of government the judiciary and
the legislative branch we can't allow
that to happen things like that that
that um
create this atrophy in the foundation of
america will destroy america it's like
lincoln said we're not going to be
destroyed from foreign forces coming on
in it's going to be from within if we
allow things that are so
anti-constitutional um to um
to be able to use sir for instance the
balance of power so yes uh dan sullivan
is right you know is she talking about
abraham lincoln because i don't what she
she said it's like lincoln said
that let's really analyze it's like
lincoln said
we're not going to be destroyed from
forces coming on in
it's going to be from within if we allow
things that are so
anti-constitutional
to be able to for instance usurp the
balance of power
i guess she means we must protect
ourselves from domestic threats
more than foreign threats is that am i
succinctly summarizing what she meant
there
um i don't know
i genuinely don't know but sarah palin
continuing to visibly struggle to use
the english english language to
communicate we have a voicemail number
that number is 219 to david p
will the trump fbi raid
get more republicans voting in november
that's the question this viewer asks
hey david sanji in wisconsin just
finished voting in our primary and i
realized after last night's raid on
mar-a-lago
i wonder if this is going to bring out a
lot more republicans than normal
which is not good for wisconsin because
we have our governor's race
and senate race where i'd like to see
ron johnson go
yeah this is a completely reasonable
question and during our live stream
yesterday of the fbi raid of donald
trump's mar-a-lago house and toilet and
safe and everything one of the things
that i was saying was
is it possible that republicans will be
so in the magats mostly will be will
they be so infuriated by the raid that
now all of a sudden they will be
revitalized and inspired to vote in
november it's absolutely possible at the
same time
would that be a reason for a law
enforcement
agency
not to do what the evidence says they
have to do of course not you have to do
what the evidence says and if at this
point there's probable cause to say we
believe that there is evidence of a
crime at mar-a-lago
and it could be in trump's personal
quarters
it could be in his safe
then you have to follow that and then
deal with the repercussions as they come
we i don't want the fbi you know one of
the problems with the fbi in the past
that we've talked about is
they take actions that seem to go above
and beyond like for example james
comey's second press conference about
hillary clinton which arguably lost her
the election in 2016. was that a
necessary press conference no
they did an investigation there was
already a press conference why do a
second one
here i don't want the fbi saying well
maybe because it'll hurt no if there's
probable cause and you have the evidence
and a judge signs off on it and you've
got all the eyes dotted and t's crossed
then you have to do what the evidence
says and we will deal with the political
repercussions we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today we're going to talk
about the new funding for the irs and
the reconciliation bill and what that
might lead to
we will talk about a town dissolving its
police department after a police officer
sent a racist text and we will talk
about ron desantis trying to suspend a
prosecutor and how the prosecutor is
reacting all of those stories are on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com become a member that's
our primary funding source for this
program and you will get instant access
to the bonus show we will see you on the
bonus show in mere moments